the enemy is not hiding anymore the
enemy is out there you see in movies TVs
music you know recently we saw this
concert at Travis Travis Scot yeah yeah
that was a huge ritual that ritual I
mean his the stage looked like something
out of heronimus BX was a portal because
it looked like a devil's mouth or
something so that wasn't just a
coincidence cuz they tried to poo poo
all the criticism and they said no no it
was just you know provocative imagery
people like me that we come from that we
knew that was a whole ritual right there
I believe he got the power through
Satanism and through this type of of
thing so for him to go to the next level
you have to do something you have to do
some sort of sacrifice that was a huge
thing right there that he did the
platform was a portal the sounds that
they were playing when that was
happening there are really low sounds
that open in the spiritual realm portals
of death and portals for these demons to
enter so what was happening there it was
a sacrifice a human sacrifice people
died at this concer lots of people